Clyde, thank you for being here.
Tell us what have we got here?
Well, we have a Chinchilla from Peru.
I thought that was an
affluent rat, you had there.
(audience laughs)
A rat that had come into some money.
I've heard of... this is a Chinchilla.
I know the Chinchilla coats.
This was the animal they used
to make Chinchilla coats.
And you can tell this...
So he'd go like over here
in this part of the coat right here.
No, I'm kidding, I like animals too.
This is incredible, they feel so soft.
Very, very dense follicles of hair.
(audience laughs)
This is not so soothing
for the Chinchilla,
but for me, very calming.
This is what I do before every show,
as I have a Chinchilla
brought to me and I...
(Conan sighs)
... soothing.
Very nice.
This animal very seldom even drinks,
and it, it would never
take a bath in water,
because high up in the Andes it's cold.
Right.
The follicles are so dense,
it would probably never dry
out and would actually die,
so it bathes in dust.
Bathes in dust?
And if you put this animal in our...
I thought that was a shake and bake,
(audience laughs)
cook it up, is this extra
crispy or Cajun spice?
So if I put the Chinchilla in here,
it will take a dust bath?
I think he will, yes.
Alright, this is a amazing.
(audience coos)
Oh, that's great television right there.
(Audience laughs)
And he's done, that was it?
That's it?
You can't just take a...
and then it leaves the pan
and... that's nice Clyde,
throw it back into the dust.
(audience laughs)
This is the only way they can stay clean,
is to basically roll in dust,
and many other animals do this as well.
Is it soothing for the animal?
This is the Chinchilla at a four star spa.
A little massage right there.
(Conan sings)
You must calm Chinchilla
calm, that's incredible.
Let me show you something
else I brought along.
Let me show you something else,
alright, that sounded sinister,
when you said it that way.
I guess he's just chilling
out right here, look at this.
Just hanging out, he
can hang out, he's okay.
I hope that guy works for you.
(audience laughs)
That was an audience
member that just came down.
'I want a Chinchilla.'
Oh my God, look at this.
I took a group of people to
Tanzania on a Safari in June,
and these are found in Tanzania,
in the Rocky areas of rather dry,
almost desert like conditions.
Yes.
And it's called a Tailless whip scorpion
or some people call them
Cave dwelling spiders.
But, wait, wait, wait, which is it,
a spider or a scorpion?
Damned if I know.
(audience laughs)
I honestly...
Wait, you're whipping out a bug
and it may be a scorpion,
but you're not sure?
I don't think it's a scorpion.
Well, thanks for the scientific breakdown.
(sarcastically) I don't
know, it might be a scorpion.
I'm not sure.
How about if I put it on you?
Alright, okay I'm scared of these things.
They are poisonous.
(everyone screams)
It's on my crotch.
(audience laughs)
Off crotch, off crotch.
Okay, look at that.
Wait, that's great, yeah, that's nice.
Why do you put them on people?
(Conan screams)
Okay, look, it's clinging to you.
Alright, do you wanna put it on my hair?
Put it on my hair, all bugs
like my hair, I've found.
It's not sticking is it?
Oh my God, oh my god, it just...
What's it doing, why is it...
Why is it on my... it's
on my wrist right now.
It may be extending it's fangs.
I'm being very still,
it's doing something.
It's like probing my wrist right now.
It's taking my pulse.
(audience exclaims)
They actually do have venom.
(audience laughs)
Are you an idiot, what
do you mean it has venom?
Isn't the wrist the shallowest
portion of the body?
So if a spider, a venomous spider,
or scorpion was to attack me,
the wrist might be the most lethal place.
It will be the main line.
Yeah, incredible, what a
wonderful demonstration.
(audience laughs)
Should we remove the spiders please?
That's great.
Or scorpions or whatever they are.
How are we going to get
this one off without it...
bite or it's okay?
It's going into the... okay,
it almost went into the sleeve,
which it thought of as
a pale, freckled cave.
(audience laughs)
Alright, what's next?
Let's keep this moving Clyde.
Okay, here's another
potentially dangerous animal.
I thought you meant her.
(audience laughs)
(Conan exclaims)
What is this, I was clowning around
and I didn't see you bring out this thing.
What is it?
Accurately enough,
it's called a black headed
Python from Australia.
And these animals don't get quite as large
as some of the Asian and African Pythons.
They get about eight feet long
and they're constrictors...
Oh, constrictors, good.
(audience laughs)
Put around neck and then
mention the constricting part.
(audience laughs)
When they are ready to kill
prey, they wrap around it,
they squeeze it tightly,
and the animal dies of
suffocation or cardiac arrest.
That's great.
(audience laughs)
That's really great.
It is constricting a little bit
right now around the throat.
Is that because it senses that I'm scared
and it's squeezing.
I think he's afraid of falling,
he wants to wrap around very tightly.
Okay, alright, so I should support him,
now, could it bite you in the face,
if I jammed this into your head right now?
(audience laughs)
If I came at you with this
would it bite you in the head?
It could, yes he could.
So there's a chance
he would bite you in the head
while it was strangling me.
(audience laughs)
But, it probably would
turn around and bite you
because you have the
tail end, and you know...
But at the last second,
the Chinchilla springs from its dust bath
and saves me, alright.
He could consume the Chinchilla.
They swallow their prey whole.
Their jaws distend enough
that this animal could swallow
something as long as...
Do you ever make these
animals fight each other?
Is that as HBO kind of thing, Cinemax?
No we don't.
Fox TV, definitely, alright.
Do you want to, maybe
we should remove this.
Maybe we could hang him
on the Christmas tree
as an ornament.
(audience laughs)
Hi, how are you?
This animal was confiscated
by the U.S. fish and wildlife service.
It was an illegal animal
brought into this country.
That animal is a criminal, you're saying?
The person who brought it in.
Oh, someone brought it in
illegally, it was confiscated,
and then you went to the Lost and Found.
It went to the Lowry Park
Zoo where it lives today.
I think we have time for one more,
and this is... oh wow, look at this.
I got this one, this
looks to me like an Owl.
I need a glove, I think.
That's an owl, there's a glove here.
I get a glove, alright.
Now tell me about this Owl.
This looks like an Owl to me.
Yeah, this is a Eurasian Eagle Owl.
Owls are broken into two groups.
The typical Owls and the Eagle owls,
our Great Horned Owl, in fact,
is very closely related to this animal.
And they really can
turn their heads around
like 360 degrees, right?
Well, not 360 but about 270.
I'm pretty sure it's 360.
(audience laughs)
Let's compromise, about 310 degrees.
Is it true that their heads detach...
(audience laughs)
... and there's candies inside?
I've just been told...
I don't know as much about animals as you,
but this is a... look at the eyes.
Tell us about the eyes Clyde.
(Conan 'hoos')
Well, first of all, they can't
move their eyes very much.
It's ignoring me.
They're positioned with boney rings
that give them far vision.
Yes.
And it's almost binocular.
It's excellent for, if
you're a predator like this,
and you're looking for prey
animals at some distance.
In fact if you'd like to see
an example of how well they see
we could put that glove on your hand.
I got the glove on, yeah.
I thought this was for a medical exam.
Do we have a piece of meat back here?
We have meat, do we have some meat here
or just a little piece of meat?
What is this we're using?
Make a little clucking noise if you would,
just to get his attention.
You just want me to look stupid.
That has nothing to do with this.
Do a clucking noise?
Okay, and it's going to...
Okay, this is cool.
Alright, let's see what happens.
(Conan clucks)
These are silent flyers.
(Everyone screams)
(Audience cheers)
Wow, what an unprofessional show.
(Audience laughs)
Look at that.
I love that camera work there.
Well, should we leave it there?
I think they've retrieved it,
and it's got a woman's wig with it.
(Audience cheers)
(Conan clucks)
This thing is blind.
It's got the biggest eyes
in the world, and it's like,
"I'm sorry, I'm not getting
it, they're not seeing."